as a predominantly solo player I
understand the certain levels of
distrust and anxiety around matchmaking
with randoms in order to complete
content everyone has had the experience
of grouping up with horrendously toxic
people but at the end of the day games
like the division are always best
experienced in a group particularly
where there is content you can do on
your own but whether you're joining up
with a team to farm gear or maybe you
want to experience the dark zone in a
group situation there are a few tips I'm
going to give you on the do's and don'ts
while matchmaking into random groups
helping me with this is Kanan ants say
hello boys we'll be doing abyss to show
you what to do and what not to do I'll
break this up into four different
categories general missions speedrun
missions incursions and the dark zone
for the content of the video I'll be
assuming you're new to the game and
matchmaking hints the beginners guide
take that I've checked in the title
at this stage of the game most people
Umesh make words are quite familiar with
the main story missions a mic really
isn't required here and most of the time
people who have this turned off but if
you do choose to have yours on there are
a few tips I can give you to help
improve the experience for you and
everyone in your party firstly open mic
sir thing be aware of it and what yours
is picking up your teammates don't want
to hear your music
they certainly don't want to hear what
you're eating and not everyone likes to
hear you cursing loudly noise from your
TV partner or child is usually not what
people want to hear either especially
when in a heavy firefight these days I'm
fully guilty of this which is why I
usually have my mic turned off but he
wants to look like Daddy with a beard
but what if you don't have a mic that's
fine most of the content these days
could be done quite comfortably without
verbal communication but you either need
to be familiar with the mission will be
able to take direction from the player
leading the team again most of the
players you match up with will be so
familiar with these missions that they
can run them with their eyes closed so
you need to take their lead stick to
them what shall they run through each
section and when they've stopped to take
cover okay give them a little space you
don't want to be blocking the shot or
making them accidentally detonate
themselves with their own sticky bombs
but what if you don't have the gear to
be able to help no worries most people
are quite happy to carry you through a
mission as long as you're at least
trying to assist and the ones that
aren't and aren't worth joining anyway
if you're under geared just make sure
you have the toughness to help to keep
yourself alive
and utilize cover as often as possible
don't just sit back and cower in a
corner office suppressive fire and
revive it for quiet but the last thing
you want to be doing is running out
there and being downed every five
seconds this will just frustrate your
teammates potentially having you booted
on the next run on that note I'm
assuming that you're nourish and still
building and perfecting your loadouts
at the very least try and make yourself
tanky enough to stay alive so bump up
that toughness and equip a healing skill
more often than not people would prefer
you to do less damage but stay alive
generally speaking in most parties there
is someone that takes the point this is
usually the person who controls the flow
of the mission they are the one who
calls out the tactics and controls the
speed at which the mission is being run
watch this player every team has one if
they're good they'll be using the
strengths of the team to make the
mission run smoother and faster these
are the players that could teach you how
to run the mission the point man
generally knows where in what enemies
the mission will spawn and will fire on
the most important targets first even if
you don't understand focus your fire on
these targets first it'll likely make
more sense later on after a few more
runs
so you're starting to get the hang the
mission now why not show the random is
what you've learnt and that you can now
handle yourself a team that runs well
together can often put you into a false
sense of security
the longer the team runs the easier the
content gets and you can forget how
difficult the enemies actually are
regardless of how well you're doing
don't charge your head into a room
randomly on your own getting killed
prematurely only adds another layer of
difficulty to the mission no matter how
easy the mission feels remember to play
as a team not a solo player the best
player in the world cannot charge you
here to complete the PvE content as well
as a team working well together the
majority of these tips should be used
through the next couple of sections -
these are the more generic matchmaking
etiquette but there are a couple of
extras I'd like to chuck in here to
avoid the giant red circles please dear
God wait until everyone is in the
elevator before pushing the button I
mean seriously there is nothing more
frustrating I will hunt you down and I
will find you and as funny as it is
please refrain from blowing up gas
bottles next year teammates
these emissions that people generally
like to run through as fast as possible
especially when they're global events on
they're running through it quickly to
maximize the number of credits the
gaming per hour an example of this is
the challenging mission Lexington Event
Center which can be run through in under
ten minutes even with a non optimized
team we also have legendary missions but
I'm not going to talk about these
because if you're watching this you got
quite ready for these yet rule of thumb
with speed runs just keep moving if you
can learn the mission before grouping up
or learn to follow directions keep up
with the group don't stop to open up
random chests or play echoes be fully
stopped before you start matchmaking
running out of ammo and or med kits in
the first room is less than ideal there
is no reason why you should have to
refill it every restock crate you pass
once per mission is usually more than
enough and when you do try to pick a
crate that doesn't slow down the rest of
the team there's your bag starting to
get full of gear pick an appropriate
time to deconstruct like when you're
having to listen to the ramos spiel for
the thousandth time if you are wanting
to sell gear and CID or you need to go
back to the base of operations for some
reason leave the group if you're not
comfortable being the point man pass the
leader role to someone else in the team
the leader needs to give the team enough
time to collect loot but also you start
the mission as quickly as possible I
know this sounds pretty intense but
these are the sort of missions that
you're likely to have the most trouble
with other players if you're jumping in
with other players during goggle events
they're all really frustrated because
they've run the mission a hundred times
and still haven't managed to get the
gear they want so any small hindrance to
their credit burn and could result in
you being booted them dropping out of
the group or verbal abuse
while the most part incursions require a
full team so if you want to try your
hand at these you don't have to
matchmake a lot of players won't have a
problem running a new player through the
incursion for the first time but even
still they'd recommend checking out a
couple of videos on it before jumping in
so you know what to expect and what
build you probably should have equipped
because in my experience if a group
wipes a couple of times in an incursion
people start to leave so just follow the
lead of the more experienced players and
watch how they tackle each area of the
map start with some of the easier
incursions first easiest to most
difficult to I'd rate them in this order
Dragon's nest Falcon lost clear sky
stolen signal incursions take a little
more coordination than story missions so
Mike can certainly make things a lot
easier
but because of the group coordination
required decide on whether you're ready
for incursions if you're under geared
you won't have a good time
I all very really matchmake with randoms
in the dark zone unfortunately
match-made groups in the dark zone are
the most unpredictable and sometimes
quite toxic but if you wanted to give it
a try you need to treat this area a
little different to the rest of the
content firstly more often than not
you're expected to have you mic on
secondly you need to establish pretty
early on whether the team you're running
with there's wanting to farm or PvP and
even if the intentions are to farm
there's no guarantee that this won't
change within minutes of entering the
dark zone whether you - the dark zone
with a group or on your own you should
always be prepared for PvP in some way
or another a couple of things to note
don't stray from the group if you die
for some reason particularly in PvP
spawn and regroup as soon as possible if
someone leaves your group unexpectedly
especially if they know you have a nice
item beware they may go rogue on you and
on this point don't tell randoms you've
just picked up something good if you'd
like more tips on the dark zone check
out my video featuring Cain as my rogue
interpreter
this was obviously a little bit
different to my recent videos but
they've been a bunch of new players
jumping into the game recently and a
beginning asked a few questions about
this along with a number of other things
on the beginner's guide series a special
thanks to Kane and Anse for helping out
on this particularly Cain who leaned it
out his angelic voice I leave a link to
their channels in the description you
often see me popping up in Kane's
streams check them out when you get
shots now for the winner of the agent
watch competition there were quite a few
entries but congratulations to Carlos
from Massachusetts and United States
I'll be in contact with you soon thank
you again to Ubisoft Australia for
providing these and a number of other
goodies if you missed out on this one
don't worry I have a few more I'll run
some more drawers on the channel I just
called in probably my patreon page too
so look out for them speaking of which I
really must thank the awesome people on
the screen right now in particular div
Errol and foxy you guys are seriously
helping with keeping the channel ticking
along thanks again anyway that's all
from me this week and I'll see you in
the next video Cheers
[Music]
why
day
[Music]